these misconnections are a big hit here
we used to do most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week and we'll there hasn't
haven't forgotten about that every now
and then I come across with some [ __ ]
but you know I do stuff and then I get
it poppin and then I leave it that's
what happens man you said it and then
you forget you said it and you forget it
I'm Ron Popeil in this [ __ ] I'm Ron
Popeil in this [ __ ] this one starts off
flyer by the way this miss connection
starts off fire I unclog pipe and offer
stress relief unload robots I unclog
pipe I unclog pipe and offer a stress
relief unload and offer Straus really
fun load I unclog pipe and offer stress
relief unload II won't need all that's
the sound of the bed you know aren't we
all just like I'm offering here's the
body I'm offering oral service to I mean
dude this couldn't be more off dude the
least sexy thing and which makes it the
most sexy cuz everything's a full circle
but is it's to say offer I offer you
here we go I am offering a little
service to give your pipe stress really
relief come get drained average big
thick stocky husky football player build
men sand your stats height weight
location picks I'm offering oral service
heck to give your pipe stress release
relief o sadand end
would you like release relief and then
right down to it in case there was any
doubt come get drained heck come get
drained soft color here's something for
sure you had a bad childhood
you're writing come get drained on the
internet if there's anybody out there
that wants their pipe unclogged wink and
awe and need some stress relief unload
wink hire this robot he's in the LA area
near Alhambra do not contact him though
with unsolicited services or offers I
mean here's another one
watch me blow any guys or girls want to
watch blow my load on skype or facetime
let's have some fun ASAP I like how
there's a time limit on it I gotta go to
work but if you want to watch me blow
let's do this here's my skype here's
another one Margo Margo I find myself
very attracted to you
I told you I loved your eyes you told me
you had cataract uh worst romance novel
writer of all time wait with you would
it be so hard to write the word uh
before cataract I had a you had it kind
of also not sexy oh my god baby I love
your cataracts I am nervous to make a
move not sure you would react positively
whatever this [ __ ] robots dude if you
ever read this and would like to know
more next time you see me even though
you can't really see well because you
got cataracts let me know Margo I find
that's the best right there that's the
best beginning of anyone that we've ever
had Margo I find myself very attracted
to you I told you I loved your eyes you
told me you had cataract I also imagine
just being in that situation there wow I
love your eyes Thanks I have cataracts I
mean and then the guy still likes the
person if I said to somebody enough I
thought they were like there was
something interesting about him and that
they were hot and I was like oh I want
to I want to say oh wow God you know
what yeah beautiful eyes and then the
quote-unquote hot Margo chick says
oh thanks you know I have cataracts I go
like this I go check please
I got beautiful eyes ya have cataracts
okay anyway catch you later
pivot she's got she's got cataracts she
talks about him too early in the
conversation I just said I liked her
eyes she said by the way hey man how
about this she's trying to get rid of
you what girl
right away mentions a [ __ ]
shortcoming if she likes a guy she
doesn't like you dude oh yeah beautiful
you have beautiful eyes I mean she was
so trying to shut him down
oh well you have beautiful eyes I have
cataracts Thanks
oh I'll hit her up on Craigslist
[Music]